so you're worried about your impact on
the environment maybe you just want to
recycle more or eat more thoughtfully
and good for you these handy apps can
help first take a look at good guide it
cuts through a brand slick marketing to
reveal their products true impacts just
scan a barcode to see the effects the
product has on the environment and even
on the community where it's manufactured
overfishing is devastating our oceans
but with the Monterey Bay Aquarium
Seafood Watch you can make sure you're
not part of the problem search their
database for a particular fish and see
what businesses in your area sell it or
serve it sustainably these days water is
also a scarce resource with virtual
water you can see exactly how much h2o
it takes to produce the food in your
fridge from produce two pork curious why
that Burger requires so much water this
app has the answer don't you dare throw
those batteries or construction
materials in the trash recycle nation
will find recycling centers near you
it'll even guide you to specific
facilities based on what items they
accept there's also a log that displays
what resources your recycling efforts
saved lastly we have green kitchen it's
the app for vegans and vegetarians or
just those of you looking to dabble
explore delectable recipes from Chia
fresca to a savory tomato crumble useful
and easy to use so now you can brag
about your sustainable diet just like a
good vegan would
you